Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Denise RQ
Los músculos.
Tenemos más de 600 músculos.
Representan entre 1/3 y 1/2
del peso de nuestro cuerpo
y, junto con el tejido conectivo,
nos unen, nos sostienen,
y nos ayudan a movernos.
Y tengas por hobby hacer músculos o no,
los músculos necesitan
tu constante atención
porque la forma en que
los trates cotidianamente
determina si se marchitarán o crecerán.
Digamos que estás de pie frente
a una puerta, te dispones a abrirla.
El cerebro y los músculos
están perfectamente
preparados para ayudar
a lograr este objetivo.
Primero, el cerebro envía una señal
a las neuronas motoras del brazo.
Cuando éstas reciben
el mensaje, disparan,
haciendo que los músculos
se contraigan y relajen,
lo cual tira de los huesos del brazo
y genera el movimiento necesario.
Cuanto mayor se vuelve el desafío,
mayor es la actividad cerebral,
y más unidades motoras intervienen
para ayudarte a lograr la tarea.
Pero ¿qué pasa si la puerta
es de acero sólido?
En este punto, los músculos
del brazo solos
no podrán generar suficiente
tensión para abrirla,
y el cerebro recurrirá
a otros músculos en ayuda.
Plantas los pies, aprietas
el abdomen y tensas la espalda,
generando suficiente fuerza
para abrirla de un tirón.
El sistema nervioso simplemente
aprovechó los recursos que ya tiene,
otros músculos,
para satisfacer la demanda.
Mientras ocurre todo esto,
las fibras musculares sufren
otro tipo de cambio celular.
Conforme las expones al estrés,
experimentan daños microscópicos,
que, en este contexto, es algo bueno.
En respuesta, las células dañadas liberan
moléculas inflamatorias, las citoquinas,
que activan el sistema inmune
para reparar la herida.
Aquí es donde ocurre la magia
del desarrollo muscular.
Cuanto mayor sea
el daño al tejido muscular,
más el cuerpo tendrá que autorrepararse.
El ciclo resultante de daño y reparación
al final produce músculos
más grandes y más fuertes
conforme se adaptan progresivamente
a demandas mayores.
Como nuestros cuerpos ya se han adaptado
a la mayoría de las actividades diarias,
estas no producen generalmente
suficiente estrés,
para estimular el crecimiento
de nuevo músculo.
Para crear nuevo músculo,
un proceso llamado hipertrofia,
las células necesitan exponerse
a cargas más altas de las habituales.
De hecho, si no expones continuamente
a tus músculos a cierta resistencia,
se encogerán,
un proceso conocido
como atrofia muscular.
Por el contrario, exponer al músculo
a un alto grado de tensión,
sobre todo cuando el músculo
se está alargando,
llamado también contracción excéntrica,
genera condiciones efectivas
para el nuevo crecimiento.
No obstante, los músculos requieren
más que actividad para crecer.
Sin la nutrición apropiada,
hormonas y descanso,
el cuerpo nunca podría reparar
las fibras de músculo dañadas.
La proteína en nuestra dieta
preserva la masa muscular
proveyendo los bloques
que forman el nuevo tejido
en forma de aminoácidos.
La ingesta adecuada de proteínas,
junto con hormonas de origen natural,
como el factor de crecimiento del tipo
de la insulina y la testosterona,
ayuda a cambiar el cuerpo a un estado
donde se repara y crea tejido.
Esta reparación ocurre principalmente
cuando estamos descansando,
sobre todo por la noche mientras dormimos.
El género y la edad afectan
a este mecanismo de reparación,
por eso los hombres jóvenes
con más testosterona
tienen ventaja a la hora
de crear músculo.
Los factores genéticos también cumplen
un rol en la capacidad de crear músculo.
Algunas personas tienen reacciones
inmunes más robustas al daño muscular
y pueden reparar y reemplazar
las fibras musculares dañadas,
aumentando su musculación potencial.
El cuerpo responde a las
demandas que le hagas.
Si estiras los músculos,
comes bien, descansas y repites,
crearás las condiciones para que
tus músculos sean grandes y fuertes.
Pasa con los músculos como con la vida:
El crecimiento significativo
requiere desafío y estrés.